I wish there was a way to know you're in
the good old days before you've actually
left them.
15 years is a long ass time. 15 years
ago, people were still waiting for the
last Harry Potter movie. YouTube still
had a five-star rating system and
Spongebob versus Spider-Man in Magic was
just a me. And ever since I started
playing Commander in 2011, I learned
many lessons about the format and the
game as a whole. And today, I want to
share that journey with you through 15
Magic cards, one for each year that
captured the biggest lessons I learned
along the way. Let's get started. 2011,
the year of nuclear meltdowns and
occupying Wall Street. That year taught
me that progress always comes at a cost,
but in Magic, it was always worth it. As
a new player, I hungrily proud the
internet for podcasts and articles for
tech to add into my deck, and Farraxian
Arena was one of them. I still remember
a comment I read in a forum. Fyexian
arena wins games. That's it. I was sold.
I bought a Farrexian arena for every
black deck I had and played it without
question for years following. I can't
remember how often I turn two demonic
tutor for a turn three arena. Fraxian
arena wins games.
You never really know when a stray
opinion, a random post, or a
half-hearted argument quietly slips into
your worldview. It comes from God knows
where, maybe a meme, a comment thread, a
late night conversation, and before you
realize it, it becomes a part of your
truth. You hold on to it, defend it, and
even let it shape your decisions around
it, forgetting just how arbitrary its
origin really was. And it wasn't until a
few years ago I began to really question
how good Fyrexin Arena really is. I
mean, it's good on turn three, but if
you draw it in the mid late game, in the
mid game, one turn is a long time to
wait in commander. Would I just be
better off with something like Signing
Blood or Read the Bones? Maybe. But it
wasn't until the release of this card
that I became completely sure that
Vyexian Arena has been outdated for
years, maybe even
decades. But the lack of direct
comparisons kept me deluded. And now
because of this experience, I question
every card and re-examine every staple.
Is it really pulling its weight in this
deck? This made cutting cards much
easier as nothing is untouchable
anymore. Every card has to justify and
rejustify it
inclusion. Next up is when I learned
about the power of ramp. 2012 Boundless
Realms. Back then, I mean, people knew
the power of ramp. Primeval Titan was a
thing, but for the most part, it was
cultivates in the rampant growths. They
were subtle. In Boundless Realms was
anything but. The turn after Boundless
Realms, I felt like I was playing a
different game than anyone else. And
people quickly caught on and tried to
kill me before I got to untap. And that
was when I realized among the myriad
things you can do in Commander, not many
are better than straight up gathering
resources. And greed is often rewarded.
Nowadays, it's a common saying that a
player who spends the most mana tends to
win. For me, Boundless Realms was the
card that made it really
clear. Next up, we have a lesson about
Simic. Not just the color, but the play
style. In 2013, Theos brought us the
Greco Roman mythology world of Theos.
And near the end of the spoilers,
Wizards quietly slipped in a little rare
that changed everything. Profit of
Cruix. It felt like they were trying to
police commander players, but hadn't
quite figured out where the line was.
Profit of Kruix was the card that
introduced me to the true power of simic
in commander. Patiently gathering
resources in the early game, comfortably
sitting behind the 40 life cushion and
the unwritten social rules of
multiplayer before eventually exploding
into an overwhelming flood of value. It
is by far the winningest strategy in
casual commander. And when everyone
catches on, the game becomes who can
drag the simic curve further with the
greediest buildups and payoffs. And this
was when I realized that casual
commander is an inherently broken
format. There is the best path to
victory, but it's less about whether you
win and more about how you win. I've
always liked to compare Commander to a
single player video game. Once you beat
it on easy mode, do you keep stomping
easy mode over and over? No. Oh, you go
to medium, you go to hard, and after
that, if you love the game enough, you
try wacky things like winning with no
equipments or without taking damage. And
that's what leveling up is about in
commander. Next up is the importance of
life game 2014 Resolute Archangel. Life
is a resource, they say, and the only
point of life that matters is the last,
they say. And I bought it. Cars like
Resolute Archangel that do nothing other
than gain life didn't even get a second
look from me. But that changed when I
built a Darion deck where I punched
myself in the face to get soldiers. And
when my despicable opponents learned to
target the medics, I lost a lot of
games, usually at zero life. And that
was the moment I decided to give the
angel a shot just once. And wow, did it
ever pull its weight. Life is a
resource, but more than that, life is
time. Without life gain, playing at 20
or even 10 life forces you into a
completely different and suboptimal play
pattern. Resolute Archangel is like a
reset button. With that in hand, you can
complain about getting attacked, but
deep down, you know, it doesn't really
matter. To this day, I firmly believe
that every commander deck needs some way
to gain life because in a format this
long and swingy, every life point lost
being permanent does not feel good. 2015
raised the alarm. like Very far in
Arena. This card was not first printed
in the year it represents here, but I
was introduced to it then. And it was
not the card to raise the alarm, but a
way of deck building. I remember when a
fresh new face at my local game store
timidly dropped this card on turn two.
As a self-proclaimed expert in the
commander, I was thinking to myself,
"Ooh, this guy's playing with draft
chaff." I'mma be nice and welcoming
ambassador to the community, and after
the game, I'll respectfully tell him
that it's okay to play these cards. is
okay, but there are definitely room for
and before I finished my thought, he
stomped me and the table with cards like
race the alarm and fencing ace. More
about this in the Viv video, but that
was like an enlightening moment for me.
I realized that this guy is playing at a
different level. And ever since that
experience, I aimed to build decks in a
similar way. Rather than staples, I'd
look for more synergistic and top- down
ways of building decks, especially if I
can use draft chafts in the process. And
next we are talking about the necessity
of aggro. 2016 Saskuke the unyielding.
Ever since I got bored of the civic play
style, I've been looking for aggro, but
playing aggro in commander is fighting
uphill to say the least. You're using
cards mostly designed for killing one
opponent at 20 life trying to do the
same to three opponents at 40. And the
commanders just couldn't cut it. And
this was until Saskia, who was there to
solve that exact problem. With Saskia on
board, your cards are now skilled for
commander. Saskia isn't the first or
last card to enable aggro in commander,
but definitely one of the most iconic.
It gave me the confidence to play
proactively in a sea of simic players
doing the rinkmanship, and the outcome
was surprisingly positive. Aggro is
necessary in a healthy commander meta.
If we think of the meta as an ecosystem,
aggro is like the wildfire. Disruptive,
fastmoving, and sometimes destructive,
but ultimately essential for balance and
renewal. It clears out greedy setups,
punishes overly slow starts, and keeps
players honest. Without it, the table
becomes a safe haven for dirtling and
greed, where value engines run
unchecked, and the early game stops
mattering. And next on the importance of
hitting your land drops, 2017, thematic
compass. Now, Jourier's kite was a
secret tech I learned about from
podcasts of the early days, and this one
had also been using all along until the
upgrade came. I've always been adamant
about hitting land drops, especially in
non-green decks. It is what allows us to
keep up the pace in mid to late game.
Opponents having 11 mana while you sit
at six, well, you just won't be
operating in the same weight class
regardless of how good the rest of your
deck is. And every activation when
you're about to miss a land drop is like
a better wave bobble. And the
transformation once you hit seven lands
rams you with a land that can save you
from the clouds and t fuss that will be
running around soon enough. So yeah, hit
your land drops whatever it takes.
Whether it's a mainface pull from
tomorrow or a wheel of fortune with
seven cards in hand. Hit your land
drops. 2018 generous patron. This is a
lesson about card evaluation. Generous
patron is a card released in battle bond
and is an amazing tool for the fringe
counter decks like Hopatra. But is that
it? I mean, it's played in 16,000 decks.
That's like five times lower than
freaking fog and less than half of many
partings. What? Now, if you look a
little closer, this card is a typical
trap for evaluation. These traps will
either make you play a terrible card or
think that a good card isn't made for
your deck. Both in similar ways. Look
past the distraction and generous patron
is actually one of the best green ETB
creatures out there. The green mold
drifter, I call it. Sure, it's pumping
your opponent's creatures and sometimes
sometimes maybe there aren't two
creatures combined among three
opponents, but 90% of the time it's a
three mana ETB draw too with countless
synergies. The typical stables and ETB
decks like Sun, Titan, Revelark, oh, and
clones. Cloning the patron draws you
four more cards. Sure, you might get
beat up by the creatures you pump, but
four more cards. So, yeah, evaluate
cards, avoid traps.
Next up, we're talking about when I'm
reminded that Commander is indeed a
game. Did you know that? 2019 Pendant of
Prosperity. I've always taken Commander
very seriously, seeing it as a test of
skill where smart deck building and
precise play should be what wins games.
Anything beyond that feels like noise. I
wanted every match to be pure substance,
no fluff, no distractions. So, cards
like Pendant of Prosperity frustrated
me. How could a single artifact backed
by a little bit of table talk generate
more value than the intricate engines I
spent hours refining? It felt unfair,
even insulting. But as Wizards kept
printing cards like this, the message
became clear. Commander was never meant
to be what I envisioned it as. It's a
format built just as much on
conversation and chaos as it is on
technicality. Trying to strip it down to
pure optimization wasn't just
unrealistic. It missed the point.
Commander is a game of variance,
politics, and social nuance. And at some
point, I had to accept that. Embracing
those elements doesn't weaken the
format. It's what makes it
unique. 2020 Croxa: Titan of Death's
Hunger. Ever had a commander that looks
so cool to you, but you just had no idea
how to build? Croxa was that for me. The
abilities are cool, but simply isn't
impactful enough for commander. If you
want Croa to stick around, you need to
self mill. But then Croxa eats that
self-mill five cards at a time, which
makes it hard to build any kind of
cohesive graveyard strategy. And after
all that work, you get a 66 with a
decent discard ability, but it's just
not worth all the effort. So, I shelfd
it. Occasionally looking back with
lingering frustration at a card that
wasn't designed for commander until one
day something hit me. Croakkes isn't
about the escape cost, and it isn't
about that one-time trigger on first
cast either. It's about a two- mana
creature that comes with a cast trigger,
ETB trigger, and dying trigger. The 66
body is also relevant. So, I built the
deck around the idea to get Croa onto
the battlefield as many times as
possible, whether through recasting or
reanimating and start squeezing value
from those triggers. And once I leaned
into that plan, a whole world of synergy
opened up. There are so many cards that
enable and reward that kind of recursion
and redundancy. My experience with Crosa
gave me a little more confidence in deck
building. With close to 30,000 unique
cards and magic, no matter which
commander, especially one printed in the
modern era, you can make it work. Maybe
keep it on the shelf until an idea hits
like I did, or build first and continue
to tune and upgrade. Either way, don't
give up on that legendary creature you
love. Magic finds a way. 2020 Dig Up.
Dig up is a lesson on opportunity cost.
Commander is iconic for its giant flashy
place with cards with high ceilings and
those are what we remember from game to
game. But at the same time, Wizards has
been secretly pushing cards with high
floors as well. And dig up is a great
example of that. Imagine the opportunity
cost of playing a card can sometimes be
simplified down as does it replace
itself or one level above that. How
close is this to a land? I've never
really figured out how to properly
evaluate cards like dig up, but as long
as you have a green source, it's like a
tack land, which makes the four really
high. But at the same time, is it high
enough to replace a land like the
MDFC2? This is something I'll continue
to think about as they continue to
release these cards. But I've learned to
be excited about an upgrade to a simple
effect as I am for giant splashy spells.
These high floor cards are what keep the
deck together and flowing so that you
can hope to reach for the
ceiling. 2022 Evelyn the covetous.
Whether it's due to shrinking design
space or growing demand for top- down
designs from universes beyond is
becoming increasingly rare to see
simple, elegant legendary creatures.
More and more new commanders feel like a
mashup of loosely connected abilities
which can make deck building frustrating
and unintuitive. At first glance, Evelyn
seemed like just another one of those.
She exiles cards from the top of
opponent's libraries whenever a vampire
enters the battlefield. But vampire
tribal doesn't work with stealing cards
from opponents. And I wrote it off as
another incohesive legend design. But
then I realized that the vampire part is
just distraction. The exile and steel
ability is the only one that matters
here. And I'm sure CEDH players have
come to the same conclusion. So, I built
a deck that is all about cloning and
blinking Evelyn, exiling two and then
four more and six more cards from each
player. Suddenly, I have endless fuel
and the very real possibility of winning
via milling or just sheer resource
advantage. The deck is a blast. With
many of today's complex commanders,
cohesion doesn't always come from the
surface level synergies. Sometimes you
have to peel back the layers, find the
engine that actually works, and build
around that.
2023, the Eternal Wonder. Fairly early
in my commander career, I wrote off
playing stalkers for the most part.
Either you play one or two, they'll just
be free target practice for opponent
creatures, or if you play super friends,
you end up with no friends. There's no
in between. For years, I've been
neglecting every Planaineswalker not
named Ugan until I saw the Eternal
Wonder. Not that it's extremely powerful
or anything, but the minus ability drew
direct comparison to another powerful
card from back in the day. tragic
arrogance. Now, the wanderer is of
course weaker, but similar enough for me
to take another look. And this got me to
look at more of the new planes walkers,
and I realized that many of them have
powerful enough effects that almost
justify the cost. And sometimes if you
get a second activation, that's just
great value. The Eternal Wonder reminded
me to take a closer look at a lot of the
new
Planaineswalkers, and I've certainly
found a few gems. 2024 Paul Jamar
Illusionist. Let's be honest here. How
many of you didn't know this card
existed? Well, I didn't. One of the best
draw spells for any blue tribal deck.
Another Titan of Lara. Almost. And it
just completely slipped under my radar.
Heck, I was even looking into human
tribal. Nowadays, there are just too
many magic cards being released, too
many sets, subsets, commander decks, and
keeping track of things can be
difficult, exhausting even. But
sometimes we need a reminder we don't
need to. As commander players, we don't
have to keep up with constantly shifting
metas like modern and standard folks.
Sure, there's always hype around the hot
new cards, but let's be real, the vast
majority of them won't make a dent in
your regular meta, barring the absolute
worst
offenders. Imagine if you don't update
your deck for two whole years and take
it to the average table. Will your game
be much different? Probably not. Heck,
even some well-tuned lists from 10 years
ago can probably perform
fine. It's easy to fall into a mindset
of scarcity where we feel like we need
to have everything and get bothered by
what we're missing. But it's actually
the mindset of discovery that makes
commander and magic as a whole truly
fun. It's about discovering cool cards
you never seen before, finding hidden
gems that fit your favorite decks,
adding to your collection one card at a
time. Today, Commander is not a game of
FOMO. Just play and collect at your own
comfortable pace. And finally, we hit
2025, the year where I re-examined the
fundamentals of magic,
lands. The card is Lindlum, Industrial
Regency. When they released the original
kamigawa cycle of lands, the most famous
of which being Minamo, people lost their
minds. In a vacuum, these are just
better than basics. And that's something
Magic was really careful about doing
again until Aldra when they released
this cycle of amazing lands. Yep. This
is them taking another swing and will
probably cool off for a while. I thought
basic land upgrades or even side grades
is the dangerous territory. Right.
Right. MDFC's channel lands more and
more and more. Even the one mana
cyclingers are basically MDFC's. There's
no sign of them stopping. And with the
townships in Final Fantasy, finally, I'm
forced to take a closer look at my land
base. I mean, these are just so pushed.
Early game, their lands, and late game,
you get the spell and the land of all.
And who knows what pushed pack sellers
they'll come up with in the future.
Generically good just isn't enough
anymore. Nowadays, even with basic land
side grades, we have to be looking at
synergy. Do I really need another piece
of removal or a flexible late game
threat? This does add another layer to
deck building. Maybe I'm late to the
party on this one cuz I used to just
throw BU and Awara into every deck, but
I think this is a nice new challenge
that we didn't really have before and
adds to the overall commander deck
building
experience. And finally, we are at the
end. And for those of you sticking till
now, I want to do a little something, a
giveaway celebrating 100 subs. Now, I'm
not going to advertise this anywhere
else, just to you.
and how to do it. Just uh I guess leave
a genuine comment about what topic you
wish to see next. Anything. Perhaps a
deck list I mentioned in this video or
maybe elaborating more on one of the
lessons here. In exactly one week from
the posting of this video, I'll do two
things. First, I'll randomly pick from
the comments to give out $20 on PayPal.
And the only conditions you need to be
subscribed. That's it. And second, I'll
make a video for the most uploaded
topic. I'll be doing more of this in the
future at 200 subs, 500 subs, and the
prize will be bigger and bigger. But
yeah, for now, thank you. Thank you for
watching. Commander is a journey where
I'll continue to learn and level up. And
I'm so blessed to have you all with me.
I'll see you soon.
[Music]
My swear.